detox ladies and gents hello I mean come
on I mean come on we got a spin full
look full look 360 I mean you're just
crushing it all right RuPaul's Drag Race
All Stars are season two - yes the
stakes are super high very high there's
so much money the twist would like each
each lip-sync that you win if you do
really well and you end up being top two
then that's an additional $10,000 on top
of that and that's gonna plague and it's
weekly I'm easy so I mean it's gonna
make the competition get really fierce
if I make your claws come out people
walk that money I'm there to get a crown
like I need a Weller's you right and to
piss on everybody so were there any
Queens you're surprised we're back on
the show not really I honestly feel like
that everyone pretty much deserved their
spot like I was glad to see tatianna
there it's been a long time into season
two so it's good to see like someone
given a chance from way back and the
depths of the RuPaul vault so can we
expect to be the shadiest Queen this
season it's tough because there's a few
shady [ __ ] okay I'm not three shady
I'm quite lady okay hahaha when your
first run into a season of drag race you
don't really know what to expect right
this time we know they're gonna do they
know you know we know the kind of stuff
that stunts that they have yeah they're
gonna pull em and it's not quite as
tense of course I mean there's
definitely like rivalry and
competitiveness but it's not as tense
because we're all friends and we're all
big family let's talk a little bit more
about these the twist on the elimination
right you guys are eliminating each
other I know I mean that's gotta be well
step it up I got a table well this time
around the two top winners of each
challenge each week lip-synch for their
legacy against each other and the winner
of that lip-sync has the ability while
the you know unfortunate task of sending
one of the fellow competitors home
luckily for us and for people who are
doing well in the competition it's set
up so they can only choose from the
bottom group of girls because that could
have been really interesting and very ya
know start picking off the top
competition as it goes along
it still sucks though because we
sent home one of our sisters right while
this show really has hit a stride though
and Andrew got a Emmy nominee I know
it's amazing a Jersey and I think it's I
mean I really fingers crossed I hope
that ruins because it would be amazing
not only for the network and for for you
know the whole powerhouse that is drag
race it's um it's such a good show like
without being part of it it's I'm such a
fan of the show it's so amazing it's so
entertaining it just keeps getting
bigger and bigger every year
and I feel like he's deserves that he's
worthless ass off for it what would that
kind of recognition mean to drag culture
and general do you think well I mean I
think would solidify the fact that we
are breaking into a mainstream you know
I know rue has a big opinion about how a
drag will never be mainstream when it's
like I kind of find that hard to believe
because I step back and I see it getting
bigger and bigger and more broad the
Broads are getting broader brought our
game brought everyone watch give us a
big tease like why should people tune in
to all-star season two cuz of me there
you go would you be watching it for her
go hey guys thanks for watching ET on
YouTube for more great videos be sure to
subscribe
you